start tonight with a look at a stimulus
bill that is on its way to
being passed in congress it looks like
cbs news has more
democrats and republicans working
through the weekend say they have
reached a deal on a more than 900
billion dollar coveted relief bill
moments ago in consultation with our
committees the four leaders of the
senate
and the house finalized an agreement
there would be another major rescue
package for the american people
if their citizens continue battling this
coronavirus this holiday season
they will not be fighting alone earlier
both sides said they broke an impasse
over republican senator pat toomey's
proposal to scale back emergency powers
of the federal reserve make no mistake
about it this agreement is far from
perfect
but it will deliver emergency relief
to a nation in the throes of a genuine
emergency
the measure is expected to include up to
300 dollars
a week in extended unemployment benefits
and for most americans
a check of 600 to 700 dollars
nancy chen cbs news that stimulus bill
would also provide a new round of
subsidies for businesses and funds for
schools
health care providers and renters who
face eviction